[Music]
it is a mark of an ungifted man to spend
a great deal of time in what concerns
his body as in much exercise much eating
much drinking much evacuating of the
bowels much copulating but these things
are to be done in passing and let your
whole attention be devoted to the mind
what epictetus is telling us about in
chapter 41 is pretty straightforward
you've got a contrast between the body
the soma
and what we're translating here as the
mind or literally the part of our mind
that you know sort of thinks about
things that makes uh judgments the gnome
and
from a stoic perspective it's okay to
take care of the body
but we shouldn't be obsessing about it
and that shouldn't be where our main
attention is and we'll use some examples
of how that can be instead we should be
focusing on ourselves and the part of
ourself that's most our self that is the
higher faculty the faculty of reason the
faculty of choice
what what here he's talking about as as
the mind
so
that's pretty straightforward and easy
to grasp the why question is is what is
likely to arise i think for many readers
especially when we look at some of the
examples that he's bringing up so we're
going to work our way backwards rather
than going directly through the text
and
think about the last two that he brings
up evacuating of the bowels and
copulating if you're spending a lot of
time
engaging in sexual activities then
you're probably not going to be able to
live the stoic lifestyle it's not to say
that you wouldn't have any sex at all as
a stoic he talks about that early on uh
in in the end caribbean but that
shouldn't be the centerpiece of your
existence and it is for many people and
we'll come back to that in a moment um
the whole you know it's kind of funny to
talk about evacuation of the bowels but
if you think about ancient medicine it
was concerned with what you took in and
what went out and we might extend this
not only to those functions but anything
where we're concerned with what is
uh on the one hand kind of kind of you
know shameful or embarrassing but on the
other hand things that people really do
get quite interested in talking about
and thinking about you know
what sort of deodorant do you wear
do you pick out a whole range of them
you know we we might go through a whole
bunch of other examples of similar
activities that people can get a little
bit obsessive about
now he also talks about eating and
drinking people who spend a lot of time
it focused on food and drink and the
drink would be not just you know
drinking water or drinking sodas or
juices uh but drinking other things that
we you know find give us pleasure like
teas and coffees alcoholic drinks
we could we could come up with all sorts
of other
instances as as well
now again those are things that are
gratifying to the body
they're necessary as well at least you
know drinking water is necessary um
and eating a certain amount of good food
is is uh certainly beneficial to us
but we don't want to be centering our
lives around okay when's the next meal
what's it gonna look like you know is it
going to have this kind of style to it i
just anticipating it in short we don't
want to be what later on would be called
gastronomes
similarly you know if we find that our
day is ruined because we didn't get that
special wine or beer or tea or blend of
coffee that we were talking about or if
we're very fastidious about that sort of
thing if the coffee has to be done just
like this or otherwise it's no good and
some perhaps we don't trust the
restaurant so we bring our own little
bag of coffee and i've seen people doing
this sort of thing a little obsessively
um that's that's really you know verging
on a problem as far as the stoics are
concerned
what about exercise you know you might
say oh you know exercise how can you how
can you go against that it's good for
the body right you're building yourself
up
well from the stoic perspective
although epictetus does use a lot of
metaphors from athletic competition and
things like that he says you shouldn't
be spending too much time and too much
attention
on athletics on training on what they
have in the greek as um
it's the verb for to engage in in
physical activities
if you're doing that obsessively
then you're probably
not paying attention to what's more
important which is the you the mind the
the thing that is at the core of who you
are your body is something external so
people for example who get very
obsessive about you know they get into
biking and now they have to go on this
track and that track and they have to
tinker with their bikes all the time and
make sure that their stance is just
right and talk and talk and talk and
talk with everybody else about it to the
point where you're like oh come on i
don't want to hear any more about your
biking or people who get into swimming
that way or people who get into running
running is particularly bad that way
people you know talk about the latest
race that they did and all of these
things are ways of focusing on the body
and its activities which is okay
but going a bit too far and ignoring the
things that are are closer to us the
things that are in some ways more
lasting than our body the things that
are more determinative because what
decides what your body does it's it's
your mind so the stoics think that
that's where we should have our
focus when someone treats you ill or
speaks ill of you remember that he acts
or speaks thus because he thinks it
incumbent upon him that being the case
it is impossible for him to follow what
appears good to you
but what appears good to himself
once it follows that if he gets a wrong
view of things the man that suffers is
the man that has been deceived
for if a person thinks a true composite
judgment to be false the composite
judgment does not suffer but the person
who has been deceived
if therefore you start from this point
of view you will be gentle with the man
who reviles you for you should say on
each occasion he thought that way about
it
chapter 42 is about how we ought to deal
with people who wind up
being difficult for us in perhaps
because they're difficult people to
begin with you can watch how they
interact with other people or perhaps
there's some sort of particular conflict
with us maybe we push their buttons
or they push our buttons there's a
personality conflict of some sort or
they don't like the kind of person that
they think that we are anything along
those lines so epictetus talks about
two ways in which people negatively
affect us at least you know this is how
we look at it he says when somebody
treats you ill or speaks ill of you
right so the the greek there is cacos
poi
poin can mean doing anything so you know
not opening the door for you and letting
it close in your face
you know flipping you the bird cutting
you off in traffic uh all the way to
like undermining you when you have to
make the big presentation or you know
sweeping in and taking something that
you're competing for
all of that could fit under there and
then the other is cacos lege meaning
when that person
says things badly says things that are
bad about you or in relation to you you
know they bring up your flaws they they
point out uh they make some criticism
pointing out something about you
in front of other people who who are
going to take it to heart and and who
you know you're going to get embarrassed
as a result of it or perhaps it's going
to damage your your reputation or
lose you a client or whatever we want to
to think of here he says when somebody
does this when they speak it badly or
they do something bad to you remember
that this person
acts or speaks that way because they
think
that it is incumbent upon them they
think that that's what they ought to do
literally here it's cathay kane and
that's the word that the stoics use for
duty or obligation they think that this
is the way that they should behave and
if they don't act that way
they're not doing what they're supposed
to do so
they may be totally mistaken about that
but they are acting that way because
they think that that's in some respect
the right thing for them to do
so he says that being the case it's
impossible for this person
to follow what appears good to you
but he has to follow what appears good
to himself so we have a conflict here
you don't like being treated that way
you see that as something bad for you
that person may see it as partly bad
like you know when we impose a
punishment on somebody who we actually
care about
we're not happy to impose the punishment
but we feel that it has to be done or
when we stand up against somebody saying
look you're screwing up um i i didn't
want to have to tell you this but you're
really
messing up this situation right when we
when we do that we can recognize that we
are doing it because we feel that it's
it's the right thing to do we say we
have good intentions in doing it right
we can see the same thing in another
person who is doing it and they may be
screwed up in multiple ways it may be
that they think that
they're an important person so they get
to talk down to everybody and boss them
around and kick them around if possible
in which case they're in error
right they they have an erroneous
conception of how
people ought to behave in relation to
each other but by pointing out the fact
that you think they're treating you
wrong
you're not going to change their mind
the only thing that will change their
mind is something happening on
their end now you can't of course oppose
them and try to make it painful for them
to to you know behave in that way but
there's only so many cases where you can
do that in our lives so he says
it follows
if a person gets a wrong view of things
the person that suffers is the one who
has been deceived
this is very difficult for us to hear
and this is also very difficult for us
to put into place because when somebody
talks to us or about us in ways that we
don't like or they act
in relation to us in ways that we don't
like
it's hard for us not to think that we're
being hurt or our interests
aren't being damaged but if we take a
stoic point of view
we can see that they're not actually
affecting what's deep inside of us the
core of our personality
they're not affecting our faculty of
choice they can't right they're using
their own faculty of choice we have our
own they can affect your body they can
affect your reputation
they can lose you clients they can you
know cause people to not want to call
you up or you know maybe they drop you
on social media or anything along those
lines
but they can't affect you at the core of
who you are
and
when they behave in this way
acting like jerks essentially it's
because they have a fundamentally
screwed up point of view
and who does that fundamentally screwed
up point of view harm primarily them
because it's it's actually bad to be out
of touch with reality and to substitute
some imaginary projection in place of
reality and if you observe these people
you're generally going to see them
running into problems with other people
similarly to your own case so he goes
out and he says
here's an example if a person thinks a
true composite judgment right where
we're putting two things together to be
false the composite judgment does not
suffer
the truth doesn't suffer
that person suffers the truth is what it
is and the truth is the truth of a
statement is what it is regardless of
whether i believe it or not if i don't
believe it well i'm the one who's who's
in in error then right i'm not hurting
the truth by not believing it
as a matter of fact the only person i'm
hurting is myself
and perhaps other people if i can get
them to believe my erroneous
viewpoint on things right so he says
if you you can take this point of view
then you're going to be
gentle as how it's translated here
the the the term there is
and in ancient greek this is a term that
is used as the opposite for states of
anger so calm would be another way of
talking about it you're not going to
take offense at the person another way
of translating it in religious
literature is meek
means meek in in the new testament
here we're translating as gentle or good
tempered or something along those lines
you're not going to fly off the handle
at this person who is in fact behaving
like a jerk because you realize that
they can't help themselves on some level
they could help themselves by getting
correct information about how the world
works and about their own behavior but
in the situation that they're they're in
at the moment when they're hurting you
they're kind of acting automatically
automatically like a jerk to be sure but
automatically and if they could step
back
and realize what's going on
they would in fact if they're rational
choose to do otherwise so he says that's
how you can deal with these people
on every occasion you can say he thought
that way about it that's the way it
appears to him that's the opinion that's
the viewpoint that that person has and
brings to the situation so it's
understandable why they behave that way
notice that this is not to require you
to forgive the person this doesn't
require you to excuse the person this
doesn't require you to condone their
actions you can call a bad action a bad
action but you can also be understanding
the fact that it doesn't appear bad to
them
and it doesn't appear bad to them
precisely because there's something
screwed up in the way in which they view
things
everything has two handles by one of
which it ought to be carried and by the
other not if your brother wrongs you do
not lay hold of the matter by the handle
of the wrong that he is doing
because this is the handle by which the
matter ought not to be carried
but rather by the other handle that he
is your brother and that you were
brought up together and then you will be
laying hold of the matter by the handle
by which it ought to be carried
chapter 43 is quite a famous passage and
it's very useful to keep in mind this is
one of those uh dogmata that you can
keep you know sort of stored in the back
of your mind and think about maybe once
a day just so you you know you like a
tool you keep it ready at hand for use
and in good condition and then when you
get into a situation you bring it out
and you say it to yourself to remind
yourself of how you can behave in a
situation so it's a lovely thought that
he's got here everything has two handles
one of which it can be carried by the
other of which it cannot be carried by
so imagine like you know a bag or a vase
or anything else and it's got two
handles and one of the handles is very
rough and kind of shifts around and
you've got some weight in that that bag
or that that that receptacle and the
other handle is
well set you can you can pick it up you
can carry it around that way
things in life are like that except what
the handles are are
viewpoints about the situations that we
get in and the people who are acting in
them so the example that he gives here
and we can come up with many many other
similar examples
is if your brother wrongs you
notice he says your brother wrongs you
he does do something wrong to you
do not lay hold of the matter by the
handle of the wrong that he is doing
that's one that you can't carry it by
he says you shouldn't carry it by this
handle but you're not going to be able
to do that anyway what's going to happen
if you focus on that particular handle
you're going to get angry
you're going to get depressed
you're going to be fearful of your
brother you're going to be resentful
bury it down deep inside and it comes
out in passive aggressive ways
none of these are good for you
none of these are are things that are
good for you as a person
because these are all negative emotions
that as a stoic you would want to
gradually analyze and and remove from
from your your psyche from your array of
feelings not to say that you can't feel
anything the stoics did recognize some
feelings as being good but those are not
among them for the stoics
it's also not going to help you deal
with your brother your brother is not
going to be made any better by you
getting angry at him and shouting and
storming out or issuing threats or you
know getting him back later on with a
practical joke and
of passive aggressive way your brother
is not going to be improved by you
avoiding him by you sulking by any of
these sorts of things by you posting
stuff on social media about you know
your family whether you come straight
out and call them out or whether you do
what they call vague booking where you
just say some some you know things and
let people draw their own conclusions
none of that is going to be helpful
that's the wrong handle by which to
grasp it so how should you grasp it he
says you can grasp it by this handle
that he is your brother
and that you were brought up together
and then you will be laying hold of the
matter by the handle by which it ought
to be carried it ought to be carried by
that handle because if you remind
yourself of these sorts of things
then you will be able to look at your
brother as somebody who you have a
certain relationship with that you want
to preserve a relationship that comes
with certain obligations on your part
even if that jerk isn't
you know fulfilling the obligations on
his own part
you have a choice
about which handle you want to grasp
these things by
this is a very powerful reminder
quite often we feel as if we only have
one handle i can only grasp it by this
we forget that we do have a choice that
we ourselves are involved in the
situation we look at the situation in a
passive way as if it's just completely
impinging on us it just is what it is
and we have to accept that even though
we might not accept what we don't like
in the situation
we have a choice in how we frame the
situation to ourselves and where we
place the emphasis as far as our own
actions as far as our own thoughts as
far as our own
uh choices
as far as our own comportments towards
other people
that's the choice for the other handle
we have to remind ourselves that there
is this other handle or else it's not
going to come to mind immediately for us
this is a very important part of stoic
practice
so
this can be quite useful to remember
that there's two handles to everything
everything epictetus is saying
everything has two handles one handle we
can't grasp it by we can't carry it by
we can't endure it by the other handle
is well suited to that this is sort of a
reminder
that the universe is not out there to
get us
and we have the capacity to intervene
positively
in ways that will help us make progress
on our path
[Music]
you